[Musique]
depuis deux mois le mot est sur toutes
les lèvres
on ne va rien au micro le varia s'est
répandue sur la planète comme une
traînée de poudre microlease probably
immense cannes 13 des cas sont plus
nombreux que jamais les systèmes de
santé traque la situation dans les
prochaines semaines elles vont être
critiques les incertitudes sont
nombreuses mais que sait-on vraiment sûr
au micro
[Musique]
26 novembre 2021 la propagation du virus
par afrique du sud et au botswana attire
l'attention de louer baisse d
un nouveau variant circulent et sa
séquence génétique n'a rien de rassurant
au micro comporte une cinquantaine de
mutation par rapport au virus originale
un nombre anormalement élevé le variant
delta par exemple en compte une
quinzaine
les experts s'inquiètent surtout de
l'emplacement de ces mutations
la majorité d'entre elles se situent sur
les spicules une protéine à la surface
du virus le spicules permet au virus de
s'accrocher aux cellules et les infecter
des mutations sur le spi qu'une aide le
virus a déjoué en partie le système
immunitaire même chez les personnes
vaccinées
par ailleurs au micron se répand bien
plus vite que le virus original et ses
autres variantes au québec ils
représentent 20% des cas de comédie 19
le 12 décembre et ce taux grimpe à 80 %
ou est une semaine plus tard en revanche
les données actuelles suggèrent que le
variant au micron cause des infections
moins sévère car il est affecté ses
mines différemment les coronavirus entre
chez d'humains par le nez et la bouche
en se multipliant
ils descendent long des voies
respiratoires
s'il se développe dans les poumons et
atteint d'autres organes vitaux des
complications graves survenus
au micron a toutefois changé de
stratégie plusieurs études préliminaires
remarque ce variant peine affecté des
poules ans il se développerait surtout
dans le haut du système respiratoire
ça contribuerait à expliquer plusieurs
phénomènes plus concentrés dans le nez
la gorge le virus fait moins de dommages
et se transmet plus facilement
[Musique]
à ce jour on ne sait pas à quel point la
vaccination freine ses transmissions
mais une chose est sûre des vaccins aide
le corps à se défendre contre au micron
une fois infecté ils rendent les formes
graves de kobe 19 moins fréquentes selon
une étude britannique les risques
d'hospitalisation serait réduit de 65%
après deux doses et de 80 1% après trois
doses
la vaccination permet donc de
désengorger les hôpitaux mais aussi de
prévenir l'apparition de nouveaux
variants car le virus mais plus
difficilement dans un organisme venant
en mesure de combattre
aussi selon une étude sud africaine les
personnes qui ont été infectées par au
micron posséderait les anticorps
nécessaires pour contrer la souche delta
la vague au micron pourrait alors freiné
et variant plus agressive et contribuer
à développer une certaine immunité dans
la population
les chances de voir lakovic 19
éventuellement disparaître sont minces
mais la pandémie ne sera pas éternelle
pour autant
si la transmission diminue et se
stabilise sur une assez longue durée la
maladie sera déclarée endémique au même
titre que le rhume et la grippe mais
accused of de panique baxi nitoo bishr
fairly and quickly with all countries of
the world au cours des prochains mois
l'accès mondial au vaccin sera l'ange
taille il jouera un rôle clé pour mieux
contrôler l'évolution du virus plus de 3
milliards de personnes n'ont pas encore
reçu leur première dose
plusieurs facteurs seront aussi à
surveiller comme les quatre autres
variantes existent en classe est
préoccupant et l'arrivée de médicaments
pour traiter lakovic 19
pour l'instant la suite des choses est
difficile à prévoir car le virus est
passé maître dans l'art de déjouer les
pronostics
mais nous apprenons de semaine en
semaine annuelle connaître
[Musique]